das hatte ich vor allem in der ersten
zeit so diese gedanken dass er sich da
unwohl gefühlt hat und dann auch noch
ausgerechnet auch noch da sterben muss
und er hat immer hat die hoffnung nie
aufgegeben hat immer gesagt nach
weihnachten wird er nicht mehr nach
sedrun fahren so das war irgendwie für
ihn klar dass es klappen wird und dieser
satz der geht mir auch nicht nur aus dem
kopf dass er wird nach weihnachten nicht
mehr umfahren und letztendlich war es ja
so nur unter diesen tragischen umständen
weil man ist ja vermutlich mit seinem
anzug hängengeblieben und was sehr
wahrscheinlich dadurch gestürzt
er hätte wasche vielleicht besser
aufpassen müssen aber das ist bei allen
unfällen wasser ist denke ich so und
andererseits werden die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen schon so gewesen
wie sie jetzt an dieser stelle sind wäre
es wahrscheinlich gar nicht passiert so
sind meine vermutung
also diese kiste habe ich irgendwann ja
so alle möglichen sachen gesammelt vor
allem die ganzen beileidskarten die ich
erhalten habe
und hier noch das portemonnaie dass man
es mit fünf euro schein
der ist uns irgendwie wie damals bei
unserer hochzeit durchgerissen und der
ist auch über irgendwie noch ist noch
hier drin
das habe ich jetzt auch alles so
gelassen
jetzt habe ich hier noch den stein den
aus dem berg den hatte mein mann will
man irgendwann mitgebracht dürfte man
nicht aber es war halt zur hochzeit ich
glaube das ist dann mal eine ausnahme
wert
da sind jetzt fotos in die schweiz
gekommen sind und über den oberalppass
fahren und genau da sind wir dann nach
sedrun gekommen das war eine total
schöne zeit und ich bin froh dass hier
auch das so gemacht haben dass ich
wirklich diese anderthalb jahre oder
fast anderthalb jahre
dort war weil wir die zeit noch mal
richtig zusammen genutzt haben und mir
dann auch viel zeit füreinander hatten
und das war schon tolle zeit wäre ein
guter vater
super war der er ist sogar nachts
aufgestanden und hat die flasche gegeben
damit ich schlafen konnte
das war schon ein ganz besonderes gefühl
letzten familie zu sein dass weihnachten
ein weihnachten hatten wir zusammen als
familie
also eigentlich war jonas so der einzige
bei dem ich das gefühl hatte so dafür
lohnt es sich weiter zu machen und mit
ihm hatte ich ja auch eine ganz direkte
verbindung auch zu meinem mann und das
hat mir schon viel kraft gegeben
die hand markt meinen sohn besonders
gerne wenn er hier ist
da muss er dann jedes mal schauen ob
seine hand noch rein passt oder nicht
sie passt nicht mehr
wo in jonas lebt man ja auch weiter
deshalb finde ich ist das mit der hand
was ganz besonderes